- Today I'm having strangers meet
and have a conversation
without seeing each other.
Make sure you stick around to the end
to watch them meet face to
face for the first time.
(calm music)
- Wanna ask a question?
- Okay. Yep.
- Go for it.
- I'll go first.
(both chuckle)
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- What's something I
wouldn't believe about you?
- What made you stop loving someone?
(laughing)
- Can I choose a different one?
- [Speaker] If you want, yeah.
- That's up to you.
- Hold on, let me see.
(both laughing)
Let me choose a different one.
(all laughing)
- Oh God.
Finish the sentence,
I wish I had told my ex.
- I wish I had told my ex.
- Blank, yeah.
(both laughing)
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- Why you gotta go so deep with me, bro?
- I just, I do what the cards tell me.
- Okay. Okay.
- I wish I had told them
that my internal pain
wasn't their fault.
- Mm.
Wow. Okay.
- What about you?
(both laughing)
- I wish I had told my ex
that I wish we slowed things down more
instead of moving so
fast in our relationship.
- Yeah.
- Because I feel like as fast as we moved
it helped bring our
relationship to an end.
- Ooh.
I wish I had told my ex that I
understand his addiction now.
I just never understood it all that well.
And he'd had addiction issues
since he was nine years old.
So there's just so much
more like development
that he had had based
around substances and yeah,
I just, I would tell them that.
- What's something I
wouldn't believe about you?
- What's something you
wouldn't believe about me?
There's something that most people
wouldn't believe about me,
but that's because they can see me.
- Okay.
- I've lost 175 pounds.
(gasps)
- Oh my goodness.
- So maybe you won't believe that about me
once you see me at the end of this.
But other than that, I don't know.
- That's incredible.
- I am a gigantic sports fan.
- Really.
(laughing)
- People meet me and the first...
That's not the first
thing they think about me.
So when football season rolls around
and I'm like ready to go,
I'm not really great at
either of those sports,
but I love them.
- You love watching them.
(laughing)
- What's something I
wouldn't believe about you?
(calm music)
- I almost died multiple times.
- In Chicago?
- Yeah.
I never thought I would see 25.
'Cause a lot of my homies and
a lot of my family members
died before 25.
- Right.
- What about yourself?
- I always told myself 23.
- Right.
- When I hit 23,
this is like when I was
like 14 and like growing up,
I was like, "Once I hit
23, I'll be old enough.
I've seen enough of the world."
- Right.
- "I'm just gonna go out."
- Right. Just-
- Better by my own hands than
someone else's, you know?
And then I hit 23 and I'm like,
"Wait, life's pretty good.
There's some good stuff out here."
And then I'm like, "Well,
maybe when I'm older and
I'm 25" and I'm like, "Man,
why didn't I ever think that way?"
- Right.
Said, I ain't going no more.
I'm gonna see 35, for sure.
- Yeah. And then 45.
You've got a long life ahead of you.
- Yeah.
- How old are you?
- I'm 26.
- 25.
- Oh, 25.
- Oh, 25. Okay.
- Yeah.
So we going through a lot life that's...
You know, we still learning.
- Yeah. It feels like an age
where you're supposed to know everything,
but you don't know anything.
- I have a lot of older
people that tell me like,
you know, you're not
really gonna know anything
till at least 30.
Like your life really doesn't start
till you're 30 years old. You know?
- Yeah.
- And from then on and then forth,
you're gonna know all the
mistakes you made in the past
that you don't want to continue to make.
- Yeah, I'm still making them though.
- Yeah. Hey, we still
young though, brother.
- Yeah, thank you.
- We still young.
- All my friends are always like, "Man,
you're so old."
I'm in my twenties, what
are you talking about?
- I'm 26. They telling me I'm 30 already.
- Yeah, exactly.
God, don't do that to me.
- Like, not yet.
I try to pick up my views
in life a little bit faster
because I always had to live
older when I was younger.
- I feel that.
- Yeah.
- You can't let go of
your youth though, man.
- Yeah.
- You gotta maintain some
childlike wonder about the world.
- Yeah.
- What's a song lyric that
reminds you of someone.
- I don't know if you've ever
heard the song "Fine Line"
by Harry Styles?
- I don't think I've heard
that one specifically.
- Well, there's a song lyric that says,
"Put a price on emotion. I'm
looking for something to buy."
And that lyric,
I would say it reminds
me of like my past self
just because for a while, like,
I just kind of felt like I
didn't feel anything like at all.
- Yeah.
- And so I'd be constantly looking
for like short term
things to make me happy.
- Yeah. Like get that quick dopamine cake.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Yeah.
- And so I think like putting
a price on like emotion,
like on anything and like I'm
looking for something to buy.
I don't know, whenever
I first heard that song
I was going through that time
and it actually really
got me through a lot.
How about you?
- Oh God. There's one called Icarus.
The story of Icarus in Greek mythology
is where he's got like wax wings
and he flies too close the
sun and he plummets down.
And it kind of reminds
me of my dad, honestly,
because he just, he put himself
out there for everybody.
- Yeah.
- And he did so much and he tried so hard,
but he never reached out.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like he just
ran so low on stamina
that just like in the heat
of the moment, you know,
he ended up taking his own life
but he just burned so bright for so long.
- Wow.
Wow.
I'm so sorry about your dad.
- It's good. Thank you though.
- Thank you.
- I don't know about
a specific lyric, but-
- You can say a song.
- A whole song would be "Just
Like Heaven" by The Cure.
- Yeah.
- Because I just heard it a lot growing up
and my mom told me she wants
it played at her funeral.
- Right.
- But like, it sucks.
That's such a good song.
So now every time I hear it I get sad,
but I wanna still enjoy it.
- Yeah. I relate to that.
- What about you?
- The song is called
"Bang Bros" by Lil Durk.
Every time I hear that song
it reminds me of my brother that passed
because it's something
we used to listen to
before he died.
- Right.
- And it just, every time
I hear it, it just...
That's why I like to space that
song out when I listen to it
and I hear it too much.
- Definitely.
- Just 'cause every time I hear it,
I want it to just be a
strong memory for me.
- If you don't mind me
asking, how'd he pass?
- He was murdered at a house
party in October, 2013.
- Yeah.
I'm sorry to hear that.
- So what part of Chicago were
you in if that was happening?
- South side?
- Yeah.
- It's a strong part of our life. Like-
- Definitely.
- As much as we try to get away from it,
it's hard to get away from it
because it's just a everyday thing for me.
Like, you know, everybody
don't grow up the same.
But where I came from,
where I grew up, it's just,
it was just a part of my life
that I try the best to get away from.
It's one strong reason
why I came to California
because like I knew that if I stayed there
more worse things was
gonna keep happening.
So I'm like,
if I could have a chance to
come out here and stay out here,
I'm gonna stay out here.
And I feel like as a man,
it made me a better man out here
where I'm not a angry person.
- Yeah. That's important.
I know a lot of men like that.
- Yeah.
- They just wanna...
They got something on their shoulder
and they can't get rid of it.
- Yeah.
- What's the most heroic
thing you've ever done?
- Oh goodness.
I mean I...
Oh yeah.
I saved my grandpa and my
grandpa's dog from the pool once,
I was like 13 years old.
They had like a 14 year old
dog that was blind and deaf
and it walked straight into the pool.
My grandpa jumps in and
then he starts drowning.
The dog is like above water.
My grandpa's under the water
and then none of my family
responded, so I just jumped in.
I guess that's heroic
in a way. I don't know.
Saved both the dog and my grandpa.
- Yeah. Saved a double drowning. That's...
Yeah, for sure.
That's hero level quality, air fist bump.
(laughing)
Bam.
By the end of this,
I'm curious how many we actually lined up.
- The fist bump? Probably
only one. That one.
Yeah. 'Cause I was like, yeah.
And then I didn't actually
do it, so I apologize.
I apologize for not actually following-
- I'm so hurt.
- I know. I'm so sorry,
(indistinct) so rough from
the outside perspective.
- I'm just over here looking
like an absolute fool.
- Okay.
- My family's gonna watch this.
- All right, okay.
Well, what if we do this?
We hold one up right now.
Right now. And then smile for the camera.
- Okay. Yeah.
Are you ready?
- Yes.
- Okay, cool, I got it.
(laughing)
- Are we still doing it?
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Totally.
(both laughing)
- All right. I know
you're messing with now.
(both laughing)
Yeah, okay. What about you?
- I used to work in a
psychiatric hospital for kids.
- Oooh.
- So I saved a couple kids
from like ending things.
- Oh my gosh. Yeah, that's incredible.
- Yeah.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you. Yeah.
- What are you proud of
but never have an excuse to talk about?
- Oh man.
Honestly proud of where
I am today because like,
whenever I was younger,
like I was a model fucking
student for a really long time.
And then I got expelled from school.
I went to an alternative school
as a result of that expulsion.
And I am one of two people
that isn't either dead,
a sexual offender or like,
something along those lines.
- Wow.
- So I'm pretty proud of
myself for where I am now.
- Yeah, good for you. That's amazing.
- Yeah. Thank you.
- I'm just proud of like,
who I am, like as a person,
just like having the morals that I have.
- Yeah.
- And I don't...
I wanna be like humble and everything,
but like, okay.
I've got an excuse to talk about it, so-
- Yeah. No, this is a bragging moment.
Fully, fully take it.
- Fully bragging.
I would just say that
I genuinely just think
that I'm a good person.
Like, I've done like
bad things in the past,
but I don't think that like, that...
I don't think there's really
good people or bad people.
I think that there's just like people
who do good and bad things.
- Exactly. That's...
Yeah.
- I would say that I'm more of a person
that does like good things
and I'm just really proud
of who I am for that.
- Yeah. You should brag
on yourself for that.
(both chuckle)
- Thank you.
(chuckles)
- Yeah.
- What are you proud of that
you don't get to brag about?
- Oh.
Maybe my sister.
I feel like I probably
don't talk about her enough.
Like, I don't know.
I feel like she's really like grown up
to be such an awesome individual
and I wanna see her more.
And I want our relationship to grow more.
- That's so (beep) sweet.
- Yeah.
- The thing you're proud
of is somebody else?
- Yeah. I don't know.
Yeah. I mean-
- That's so cool.
I love that.
- I Feel like I'm proud of
the way I deal with my family
because we're kind of dysfunctional,
but I feel like I deal with
it with everyone involved
in enough of a way to just
like protect my peace.
Even if there is still residual drama.
I know when to like drop
things and walk away
and obviously that doesn't come up
because who's gonna
ask me about my family?
Like, that just doesn't come up.
But it's something I'm proud of myself
for being able to develop those skills.
What about you?
- I...
(clears throat)
This is actually something I've
been thinking about lately.
I'm very proud
of the fact that I have
developed a skincare routine.
- Oh.
- And I feel like I don't
get to talk about it enough
because like, I don't wanna seem vain.
Like I sort of like sit there
and wait for the sun to hit my face right
so people will be like, oh my God, yes.
Face.
- That glow, yeah.
(both laugh)
- But like, it hasn't happened
as often as I want it to.
And like, I can't just pop out
on someone and be like, yo,
like, lately I've been
taking care of my skin.
Like, what's up?
(laughs)
- Hey. I mean, I'm proud of you.
I applaud you for that.
- Thank you for that
question. I needed that.
(both laughing)
- I moved out of my family's
house when I was really young.
- Right.
- And I was always in contact,
at least with my mother.
But about a year and a half ago
she got diagnosed with
congenital heart failure, so-
- Oh. I'm sorry to hear that, bro.
- It's all right.
Thank you.
So it's one of those things where's like,
you don't know when it's gonna happen,
but one day it's just gonna happen.
So I kind of cleaned
up my act a little bit
and move back in with her to
try and help take care of her.
I am proud of myself for at
least trying to take that step.
- It takes time.
I relate to that because
I've had people tell me about
getting close to my mother
'cause I never know when her last day is.
- Yeah.
- So like, you know,
I was mad at her for a long time
where I wanted nothing to do with her.
- Yeah. I get that.
- But I just realized
like days get shorter
and nights are even shorter.
So it's better to just be
there as much as you can
and just appreciate
every day that you can.
- Yeah. And even though,
you know, people...
Like you said, people make
mistakes, people mess up,
but there were always times
that she was there for you.
- Yeah.
- That's still your mother.
- Yeah. And that's a strong
one right there, brother.
- Yeah.
- That's a strong one.
- What's on your mind?
- Honestly, at our Airbnb
we have this frozen pizza.
(both chuckle)
- Hell yeah.
- From Trader Joe's that
I'm really excited to try.
- Dude. That is awesome.
- Yeah. That was-
- What kind of pizza is it?
- [Speaker] Cheese.
(all laughing)
- Trader Joe's cheese Pizza.
- [Speaker] Get it.
- Calling my name.
And also of course that
I think that you're a really great person.
I don't even like know you, but...
- Oh man. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- What's on your mind.
- Dude, honestly, anxiety.
(both chuckle)
This has been...
I've enjoyed this thoroughly, but-
- Yeah, me too.
- But it is very anxiety inducing.
- Yeah.
- And I almost cried a couple times.
- I know. I was like.
(both chuckle)
- Ooh, my friends.
And we've been having such a
good time today being here,
being in the sun.
It's been really foggy in San Francisco.
What about you?
- Yeah. Enjoying this experience.
I think this is really fun.
I am currently now looking at my fiance.
So you're looking at your friends,
I'm looking at my fiance, so.
- When are you guys gonna get married?
- June 2nd of 2024. We
can't change it now.
It's now on the internet, so-
- Yes.
(laughing)
Congratulations.
- We'll just link this...
We'll just send this video to people
to let them know and be
like, all right skip.
No, no, skip.
Like right there. You know (indistinct)
- It could be like save the date, right?
- Yeah. Save the date.
(chuckles)
- How long have y'all known each other?
Now I just need to know more about this.
I'm just gonna ask you-
- Yeah, no, I can give you a little more.
- Yeah.
- So I was actually...
(laughing)
So I was referring to her as my wife
a year before I ever spoke to her.
And lemme explain.
- That sounds like me too.
- So my friend...
I was explaining to my friends
that I really have a thing for bold girls.
And my friend said, "I've
got the bold girl for you."
- Oh, amazing.
- And she showed me a picture and I...
They're like, "This is Nix."
And I was like, "Oh, you mean my wife?"
And so for a whole year, for a whole year,
my friend Legend would be like, "Oh,
this is what Nix is doing."
And I'd be like, "Oh, you mean my wife?"
- Oh.
- And then like after a year
I bought some art from them.
Actually, this T-shirt they
made, it's my favorite T-shirt.
I bought some art from them
and I started talking to them.
I was like, "Oh my God,
I can never call them my wife again.
What if I ever like lord forbid date them,
then I'd have to explain
that I called them my wife
for a whole year" and now
we're getting married.
- Absolutely (indistinct)
- It's super cute.
But if it hadn't worked out
then it was just kind of creepy.
(both laughing)
- Fair enough.
But like, I think it, you know,
everything happens for a reason.
- It was a meme, she was
a meme in my life first.
- That is incredible. And I'm
staring at them right now.
Hi. That is so exciting.
I'm so happy for you guys.
- Thank you. Thank you.
(chuckles)
- How are you doing really?
- I'm doing good baby.
I'm doing great.
- I'm glad. I'm glad to hear that.
- I'm doing great today.
It's been going great lately.
Like every day is getting better
and I see my future is getting
better from here on out.
Like I said-
- That's the optimism right there.
- Yeah. It is been hard.
It's been hard growing up.
It's been hard from a lot
of things I've been through
and I doubted myself. I was done.
- Right.
- I was just done with life.
You know how you could be
done with life at times.
- Yeah.
- But when I wake up and I see the sun
and I see these trees and
I get to breathe this air,
it just makes me wanna make sure I get up
and I go forward with my next day.
What about yourself?
- Not as optimistic.
- Yeah.
- But it's definitely there.
- Every day I do just fear like,
oh, she's not gonna wake up today.
- Right.
- But despite that,
especially once I see
that that hasn't happened,
I'm very like, okay.
- Right.
- I can breathe and I'm, you know,
I'm happy to be here. I'm
happy to experience it.
Like even if something doesn't
work out, I'll be all right.
- Right.
- I'll move on. I'll be good.
- You know, when the sun come up,
God gave us another day.
We must be here for a reason.
- That's a tough one for me.
I am not a religious man, so.
(chuckle)
- Yeah.
One thing I always say is
I know the devil is real
so God has to be real.
- Yeah.
- He has to be.
We see a lot of evil things
going on in this world
that is coming from the devil.
It has to come from some dark entity.
So if the devil is real
then God has to be real.
They'll say there's evolution
and the big bang and everything,
but there's too much energy
within people itself on this earth
and I felt God within myself.
It's times where I want to do bad things.
Where I had a second voice in my head,
he tell me like, no, I don't do that.
Nah, I go this way.
- Right.
- Leave, do something different.
Be quiet, move forward.
Do better. Even if you
gotta be alone at times.
- Yeah, definitely.
Just because a path is the right path
doesn't mean it's an easy one.
- Yeah.
- That's beautiful. Faith is-
- Faith is scary but beautiful.
- Definitely.
What's the craziest thing
that happened to you?
- Oh, that's so vague.
- Yeah.
- Honestly it might just be this.
- This is kind of...
This is really outta the ordinary for me.
Being in front of a camera in general
is like not common for me.
So I'm pretty nervous right now, I'd say.
What is the most
interesting thing about you?
- My talking skills.
The way I just like to talk to new people
and just get to know
new things about people
and just see what I can
learn from the next person.
'Cause I always feel like...
I always say that the
best teacher is listening.
- I definitely agree.
Like being able to listen.
Everybody has a story.
Everybody has something to say.
You can learn from everybody.
- Yeah.
- But I don't know if I
have those talking skills
like you do.
- Yeah.
- It's hard for me to
start engaging like that.
- All it is, is you just
gotta sometimes say things
that you feel uncomfortable
saying and just say it
and just see what type of response
you can get outta somebody.
- I'll hopefully learn that from you.
- Okay.
(both chuckle)
- What made you stop loving someone?
- Something that made
me stop loving someone
was them making me feel
worse about like myself.
- Yeah.
- And like my image of myself.
'Cause I was really, really
confident for a while.
And then I was with someone
that absolutely shattered that,
like absolutely shattered that.
And that like...
I think I never really stopped loving them
until I realized that I felt
so much worse about myself
because of what they thought of me.
- Exactly.
- And so I think that
something that makes
me stop loving someone
is just for them to make
me not love me. You know?
- I mean, having someone tear
you down emotionally like that
is like so much worse than I
think a lot of people realize.
The emotional abuse part of domestic abuse
lingers so much longer than
the bruises themselves.
- Yeah.
Yeah. 100%.
- What makes your heart smile?
- Good music.
- Yes, brother.
Yes.
That is my same answer.
- Great music.
What's the last song that
made you smile like that?
- What's that Harry Styles' song.
♪ In this world ♪
- That's the one. Thank you.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. That's a good one.
- When you hear it and the
sun is out, it's just like,
it's hard not to be happy.
- That's a great summertime song.
- Yeah.
- Top down kind of song.
- What's something you
wish you would've said?
- Mm, I think it's gonna
go back to my dad again.
I wish that I would've expressed
in a more complex manner
just how much he means to me.
Whenever you're depressed and
you're that much in the whole,
like I love you can mean a lot,
but sometimes you just
feel so numb and such
that you really need it
like hammered into your head
that you are loved and you have
support and like I know that
I can't put it on myself that he's gone,
Like that there's nothing I
could have technically done
to change that fact.
But it's something that
I wish I would've expressed
thoroughly one last time.
- Yeah, I understand that.
- What about you?
- Something I wish I would've said.
My older brother,
he has like literally loved me so much
since the day that I was born.
Like absolutely like the best big brother
like anyone could genuinely ask for.
But I just never like
appreciated him at all.
He didn't have to like
act that way with me.
I was just like get so annoyed with him.
Never wanna be with him,
never wanna hang out with him.
Always embarrassed of like
my like older brother.
But like, he just loved me so much
that I really wish I would've
like appreciated him more
and like told him that
like I loved him more.
Him and I really aren't that close anymore
because he tried so hard with me
and I just would never
like reciprocate it to him.
So probably that.
- I'm surprised that like I
don't feel anxious anymore.
- Yeah.
- I'm pretty comfortable
sitting here talking to you at this point.
- Yeah.
- Are you the kind of guy
that likes to do karaoke?
- I could do it. Sometimes I get nervous.
(both chuckle)
- Yes sir. Me too.
That's one thing, no matter
what, I cannot do it.
- Just gimme a song that I know
and then yeah. I'm up there.
- That's courage.
- You cool people bro?
I swear like at first I
was a little bit nervous.
- Yeah.
- But like, you made the
conversation go easy.
- I appreciate that.
- Yeah.
- Based on this one conversation,
I think you're the most
optimistic person I've ever met.
- Yeah. Really.
- I feel like no matter what happens,
you're always gonna
find a way to be happy.
- Yeah.
(indistinct)
- I really appreciate that bro.
- What is your star sign, by the way?
- I've been told I'm a Leo.
- You've been told you're a Leo?
- What's your sign?
- Gemini.
- Gemini? Okay, cool.
(laughs)
- I'm gonna go ahead and guess Aries.
I'll guess Aries.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- I'm right? No way.
- I'm going to guess Virgo.
- Oh, you're wrong.
I'm a Sagittarius.
- I'm thinking Libra.
I'm thinking Taurus.
- Taurus?
- Yeah.
- That's my moon.
- I'm a Taurus.
- Oh gang gang. Yeah.
I'm a Virgo.
- Oh, what's yours?
- I'm a Libra.
- Oh, okay.
One of my homies is a Libra.
- Oh, I thought it was like a ah man.
- Oh no.
- 'Cause I'm not gonna
lie. There's (indistinct)
Like again,
we're not supposed to be
the greatest of friends.
- Yeah. Nah, I mean,
my grandma's a Libra and my homie a Libra.
So like (indistinct) Libras.
- There you go.
- Cancer start like June 28th.
- Okay. So it's early June-
- Or 21st?
- Dang. So I wasn't even in July.
I was a whole month off.
- I'm a real Cancer though. July 6th.
- Dang.
- I'm the realest cancel. (indistinct)
- [Speaker] I'm gonna hand you that.
Hold on to that for a second.
And you guys are each
gonna do your best drawing,
what you think the other
persons looks like.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah. I told you I'm an artist.
Hold on.
- I am not.
- I need like a table.
(both chuckle)
- Please don't make me do this.
(laughing)
- [Speaker] You got it. It looks great.
Really, it looks amazing.
It looks amazing.
- Whatever you see it's
not 'cause your bad,
it's just I'm a bad artist. All right.
(laughing)
- I hope you won't judge me
based off my drawing of you.
- Oh, I mean, based off my
drawing, you will judge me.
So.
- I need a pencil.
I could sketch better with a pencil.
(both laugh)
- Okay. I tried to draw waves.
- You wrong, I can tell you now.
Do you got like a taper?
- I had a taper but it's
kind of shaggy right now.
I need to get it cleaned up.
- But that's like your normal
cut is like you get a taper.
- [Speaker] Don't you guys-
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- (indistinct) did it.
- What ethnicity do you think I am.
- Mexican.
I got black skinned homies.
So like, I don't know.
I mean, I ain't trying
to be like, you know,
stereotypical.
- Hey (indistinct)
- Hold on, I get you.
(laughing)
- Oh god.
Dang. Are you doing full body?
A background?
(both laughing)
- Nah, they lying.
(speaker speaks indistinctly)
- He got the address and everything.
It's just eagle eye view.
(indistinct) my mama?
(all laughing)
- Okay, I think I'm done.
- [Speaker] All right.
So hold it up to your face so
that this camera can see it
and hold it there for a
second until I focus on it.
There you go.
All right. I wanna make
sure this one's (indistinct)
In front of your face so
that the camera sees it.
- I'm gonna get it closer, maybe.
You tell me where to put it.
- [Speaker] Okay. So
that's what you guys think
that the person looks like?
- Oh man.
- [Speaker] That's amazing.
Okay. Show to me.
(laughing)
- This is the worst thing I've ever done.
- [Speaker] (indistinct)
so that the cameras get it.
Like in front of me. Yeah, there you go.
Perfect. Go ahead and put...
Hold them up, hand it to each other.
Okay. You don't open yours yet.
- Okay.
- [Speaker] You can go ahead and open it.
(both laughing)
- You did better than me though. Hold on.
- No way. You were on that
thing for like half an hour.
I swear.
(both laugh)
- It ain't bad.
- Was I right about the jawline?
'Cause that's really what I felt.
- Yeah. (mumbles)
Like I want this jawline though. Hold on.
(indistinct)
- Oh, gee.
- Just keep this.
- (indistinct) Dang, I do have a mustache
but I shaved the chin.
I shaved the chin like a week ago.
Dang, that's pretty close.
I'm not gonna lie.
- No, don't lie to me bro.
- No, the only difference.
I have curly hair.
- I know. I just did...
I gave you like a afro.
I was trying to do curly,
but I did like a pencil.
(both laughing)
- It's going on my fridge.
- Right
(both laughing)
- Stop.
(indistinct)
- [Speaker] Look at it.
Look at it. Look at it.
Do you see any (indistinct)
(both laughing)
- Dude. Oh my god.
- We both have dope hats.
- Yeah. I thought you had a hat.
- [Speaker] Did you guys tell each other
what you were drawing?
'Cause you both drew same thing.
- Yeah. We did the exact same thing.
- Well, we said...
(laughs)
This is so funny.
- No shit.
- Oh no.
- Are you wearing a cowboy hat?
(laughing)
Are you joking?
What?
Yeah.
No. You're wearing a cowboy hat?
- Yeah man, I got it yesterday.
- That makes me so happy.
- That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- I'm literally keeping that forever.
- [Speaker] Stay where you are.
- Oh, hell yeah.
(both laughing)
- I got the pierce in-
- You got the bangs.
- Oh, cool.
(both laughing)
- [Speaker] All right. Now go
ahead and hand them theirs.
- I'm gonna keep this
in my wallet forever.
- Okay.
(laughing)
Oh my gosh, this is good.
Oh no.
- I thought you just
have like a very kind,
honest looking face and
I imagined a side part.
So, in long hair.
- Of course I'm with someone
who's like super into art.
(both chuckle)
- [Speaker] Go ahead and open it.
- Oh my God.
(both laughing)
- No, it's okay.
I still appreciate it.
I will put it on my fridge, so.
- If you're spot on
again, I'm gonna be like.
- I'm gonna be shocked because...
(laughing)
- How are you way more accurate.
- Am I, really?
- You're way more accurate than me.
- No way.
- She's like way more
accurate than I am. Okay?
- [Speaker] You guys ready
to meet face to face?
- [Both] Yes.
- [Speaker] Hold on.
I'm gonna fix the cameras.
- Don't tell me you're like 6'6.
I'm gonna be like a dwarf compared to you.
- Close.
- Close?
(laughing)
- I'm close to it.
- [Speaker] And in Chicago
you'll look that way.
- Oh, a weight has been lifted.
- I'm like so excited.
I'm like first day of school, feels like.
(both laughing)
(indistinct)
- [Speaker] Don't turn.
- Okay.
- Before we get to see them meet
face to face for the first time,
I wanna show you a
journal I just launched.
It's called "All the
Strangers I've Ever Met."
And basically it's a cute little journal
for you to document every
time you meet a stranger,
it has little sections
for you to fill out,
like a section for the
photo or a drawing of them,
questions you could ask them.
And my favorite page
where you'll check off
what country you met them in.
This whole episode is about
strangers meeting strangers.
My channel is about me meeting strangers
and I'm sure you meet a lot
of strangers in your life.
And hopefully now we can document it all.
If you wanna buy one,
I'll have it linked in my description
or you could go to the thoraya.com.
Thank you if you do,
it really helps with the
production of my episodes.
But if you don't, thank you still
because you've helped
support me enough already.
And now let's get back to the episode.
- [Speaker] Okay. Whenever
you're ready, go ahead.
- Oh my god.
(both laughing)
- I totally thought you looked different.
- Okay. What?
Yes. Okay, I was a little on, like you...
(laughing)
I'm Kevin.
- Nice to meet you. I'm Eva.
- Very nice to meet you.
It was extremely interesting
talking to you today.
- Yes. This was so fun.
Dude, I will be framing this.
- This the funniest thing ever, so.
(both laughing)
- I wasn't that off.
- Not really.
You got the volume there.
(both laughing)
(calm music)
- [Speaker] One, two, three.
- Hey.
(both laughing)
- My gosh, you're so pretty.
- You're pretty.
- Thank you.
Your hair's so much
longer than I envisioned.
- You're shorter than I envisioned.
- (indistinct) 4'11.
- Really?
- Yes.
- I'm like two inches away
from being legally a little person.
- Wait, can you stand up for a sec?
- Yeah.
Boom.
- Oh my gosh.
You're so cool.
- You're so cool.
- I love the face tat.
- Thank you.
A lot of people think
it's a cross but it's a-
- A dagger.
- Yeah, a dagger with dragonfly wings-
- That's really cool.
- Are you a hugger?
- Yeah, I'm a hugger.
- Sweet.
(both chuckling)
- It was a great conversation.
- Yeah. Thank you. Thank you so much.
- My bracelet broke during.
- Oh, speaking of bracelets.
Speaking of bracelets.
- Oh my gosh.
- I knew I was gonna do this
and wanted to give it to whoever.
- Oh my gosh. That's so sweet.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah.
- Can I take a digi cam of you? Sorry.
- Awesome.
- And we will be in contact.
- We definitely will.
- Yes.
That was so fun.
- [Speaker] All right, whenever
you're ready, go ahead.
- Wait count us down.
(both laughing)
- I looked immediately.
- Ready to hug?
- Yes.
Yeah, hi.
- Oh my god. Cool socks.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Oh my gosh, stop.
- Holy shit, a cowboy hat.
That's so-
- No, I knew you were wearing a hat.
- I love it. Yep, I'm wearing a hat.
- I knew you were wearing
graphic T and the cool shoes.
- The cool shoes and socks.
- And even cool socks.
- Yeah. Thank you. I dig your eyeliner.
- Thank you. Thank you.
This has been so fun.
- This has been a blast.
- Oh my god.
- It's so good to have met you
and you're coming to my wedding.
- Yeah. And I'm gonna go to the wedding.
So, and they're coming too.
- Yes, hello.
- You get plus two to our wedding.
(laughing)
- Oh my god.
- Bring it in baby.
- Hi.
- Can I give you-
(indistinct)
Yeah, of course.
- Oh. You're so lovely,
I love your eyeliner.
- Thank you.
(indistinct)
- Hello. Hi.
- Yay.
- Yaaaaay.
(laughing)
- Shout out to my ex, uh.
- [Speaker] One, two, three.
- Oh, wad up.
- God damn. You are tall, shit.
It's all right.
- So I was kinda close,
I was thinking like I
knew you curl (indistinct)
I was trying to get some earrings
'cause I know you had some earrings there.
- Yeah. Yeah. I got some big ones.
- I shoulda got the glasses.
(both laughing)
Yeah, this is fun bro.
(indistinct)
- Good to meet you.
- Yes sir. Yes sir.
Yes sir.
(all cheering)
Yeah. Chicago to San Diego.
Man. You know how we (indistinct)
- [Speaker] You guys, was that fun?
- [Speaker] Yeah, no, that was fun.
That was fun for sure.
(indistinct)
- [Speaker] Thank you.
(calm music)